um so dude I [__] so okay the first
time I brought up bivo yep and you were
like oh he doesn't swallow Y and then we
tried to like find a clip of it and we
couldn't really find like real proof and
that clip of him went viral this week of
him eating the potato and I had to say
I'm I'm wrong you were right appreciate
it appreciate it it is one of the
funniest things I've ever seen now I
don't know like I wonder Spock and I
were talking Spock goes you know this
dude had a moment where he's like I'mma
die
what like when he like when the full
potato went down there must have been a
a millisecond you can see it in his face
yeah he does he goes like he stops and
he's like oh [__]
yeah this dude drank a potato do you see
how long you can just feel the pain oh
[__] oh look right there dude this my f
one so he's a really
funny guy like do you follow him now in
his sort of escapades I let the
algorithm you know just give it to me
sometimes I tap in okay I you know I
just search people now I'm like what the
[__] Bea yeah so yeah so you've seen
like the lore with like the be like from
what I can pick up it's like he got a
little bit of attention online he just
turned into like a rapper oh like he's
got a chain that says bivo on it the
other day he's like live streaming from
his like [__] Sprinter van with this
girl and he's like you know the rules
it's speo in it this isn't you so a lot
of people are like dude the money has
gone to your head it's like what what
money he's been like you know what I
mean yeah he reviews food and it's been
he's been like it's been like a month I
don't even know how do you even get a
brand deal in that time he may not need
it that's how balling he is how what
like where is he getting money we don't
know clearly I mean look at that
Sprinter
van the chain like go go down like he's
holding it up right there the bivo chain
is so crazy you just
fart okay so you know what he's doing
right like he's just this is what he's
doing look how long this video is it's a
minute he just does this the whole
time that's how you make money on Tik
Tok now over a minute videos yeah yeah
that's true bro this got to oh this is
got to feel so good for
her like dude it's got to be awesome
when you're sitting behind bivo and he's
pointing at you to the to the world
going Mr psych your [__] they that's me
yeah so I half the people are like the
fame's getting to you bivo and the other
half are like no keep doing you Vio love
the positivity don't you can't listen to
those people man they are completely
lying to you cuz you know what they're
doing it's like Brian's friend it's like
Brian's friend who like comments on [__]
with one like going why isn't this viral
yeah
exactly feo's really out here thinking
he's a g I wish I was this delusional
damn he acknowledged the no true on one
of his older videos yeah I know now he
kind of does it on purpose too that's
what's going to get him killed dude
that's why he did that potato yeah yeah
yeah like I saw him do one recently
where it was like a big ass chunk of
meat he like I might have I might have
to actually chew this guys guys you no
we got to stop man we're get we going to
get them killed on live yeah you know
the
rules just literally like he does that
face and just
stays I was thinking he's like what's up
Tik Tok you know what it
is 15 G truffle just a hard chunk of
truffle
yeah it's like pure iron we're going to
tight this
one
damn that's dark man that's [__] dark
bivo don't do it like big up bivo big up
up big up rip [__] damn hopefully you
know the rules yeah you know the rules
you know what are the rules this is this
is the one where he acknowledges oh he's
also been turning on like the teeth
filter on all of his videos so his teeth
look vibrant white so funny they got to
him yeah he's turned into a chave that's
all it is chav transformation yeah
chav stle you know the rules this and
big up the Asians big up not you oh no
e big up the Asians this [__]
Got a Boner as he's saying this [__]
man you saw the sauce he put on that
wait no what did he big up the Asians
yeah with the smile big he said that
because he knows he's about to go to
Thailand too that's what it is yeah big
up La Big up the
Asians I wonder to know if there's any
Asian women who watch that and go
yeah me bivo me oh my God bivo mean you
know the rules and if you don't know the
rules get to know the rules baby but
come on now he Austin
poers a PO you know the ru
baby um yeah let's rate it out of 10
let's enjoy it apparently I don't chew
enough but I don't need to chew watch
chicken as well yeah chicken
oh no chew
needed he's going to die
man you keep playing it you know the
rules baby you don't need to chew your
food F you don't I true just yeah that's
the funniest thing he's ever said you
imagine some little kids watching this
[__] oh [__] if they hear this
[__] they're going to be like
just in school I don't need to cheat my
food kids kids are choking all over the
country because of this [__] bivo
dumbass P pick up to no swallow Pi have
to no swallow no I don't do that [__] M
swallowing
gay no it's just the other way be
chewing is you don't need to chew your
food you don't need to chew your
food that's so funny dude so you can
[__] oh my God so you can [__] boy while
you're eating yeah just that would be
the new technique you're on a date with
a
girl you enjoying
[Laughter]
it me
too no I'm loving it
yeah so would you say you do for work
[Laughter]
again cool no that sounds
sick no this pasta is really good yeah
yeah M the smile though whole
time he's growling a
bite yeah no it's it's lit it's
slapping this place [__] rules yeah
yeah that's the craziest type of
influencing yeah just telling people to
do [__] that'll literally kill
them that's
crazy no big up ammonia and bleach
[Laughter]
I'll be I've been mixing those on the
regular just you should you should
definitely try that you don't need to
chew your food I mean that's just the
funniest thing what a [__] guy with
the gel dude the gel in his hair the
chain I know you don't need to chew your
food man you don't need to chew your
food you could be just like me you could
be just like
me oh
[__]